Brutal rebaja del límite salarial del bara.
¿Esto qué es bueno?
¿Es malo? A mí me ha costado entenderlo,
pero te lo voy a explicar a que hagáis 1 idea.
En febrero
el bara tenía de límite salarial 648 millones
y ahora 270 millones.
Principio bueno
porque el bara tiene que bajar este límite
para poder fichar,
lo que pasa es que todavía no hemos llegado ahí.
Esta aplicación de Martín miñán me ayudó a entender 1
poquito. Te lo voy a poner,
la dirección deportiva del bara
redujo la masa salarial de 596 millones a 400
este verano de más de la rebaja del límite salarial.
¿Y qué significa esto?
Martín nos explica que de manera aproximada,
al bara tendría que reducir 134 millones
aproximadamente
para poder fichar normalmente
si se arregla del 1 1
sin restricciones salariales ni plusvalía ni nada.
El diario os podemos Dar 1 Buena noticia
que dice que el bara inició la ventana de junio con 1
límite salarial,
215 y ahora lo ha subido a 270.
Límite salarial cuanto más alto mejor.
Lo que pasa que el bara tiene que reducirlo
para fichar con normalidad.
Poco a poco. A seguir trabajando, vamos bara